in many ways the ministry of Defense are
right I think that the Russian Advance
has significantly slowed in many places
here in Ukraine we've just got back from
the city of Hawkeye up in the Northeast
very close to the Russian border what we
saw was the Russian military essentially
parked in the northern suburbs of that
City second largest city in Ukraine with
both sides essentially taking pot shots
at each other with artillery in the
woods we also saw evidence that the
Russian forces have taken heavy losses
in terms of personnel heavy losses in
terms of equipment as well but it's
really important to say that there is
intense fighting going on right around
the country there is a city not very far
from here about 200 kilometers to the
Northeast called ISM really intense
fighting there reported over the last
couple of days it's a river that slices
through the middle of the city the
Ukrainian forces are trying to hold the
Western Bank of that River uh and we
understand intense fighting and reports
of a high number of casualties these are
unconfirmed reports there are numbers in
circulation of 400 Russian soldiers
Russian servicemen losing their lives
again need to treat that figure with
caution it is unconfirmed but clearly
very intense fighting there down in
mariopol in the southeast
I mean the horror continues there that
the name of this city will live long in
infamy I believe a hundred thousand
people still in the center of that City
according to president zielinski the
Ukrainian leader these are people
without food without water without
services with the fighting raging around
them as a small number of Ukrainian
troops essentially fight to the death
situation there very Bleak very
difficult to get out of that City